un final anunciado para los tiquetes de
papel del metro de parís poco a poco se
han ido eliminando para que sólo quede
la tarjeta electrónica navigo y
es gracioso porque mi novio se la pasó
haciendo rayitas con los tiquetes y
ahora le molesta que no podrá ser más
ranas
cambiaron las décadas y también lo
hicieron los boletos del metro antes de
que se introdujera en los torniquetes
automáticos los billetes serán revisados
por agentes que los perforaban se
aseguraban de que nadie intentara
colarse en una estación
los que intentan pasar sin pagar siempre
nos cuentan historias poco creíbles pero
nosotros no somos tan malos
antes era imposible subir al metro sin
el tiquete perforado conociera
perforadora de boletos en una de las
estaciones la verdadera con la
perforadora en mano y su sombrero pero
este trabajo desapareció gradualmente en
la década de 1970 a favor de los
torniquetes que validaban
automáticamente los boletos del metro
los nuevos tiquetes tienen una franja
magnética como ésta e hicieron más
rápido y fácil el uso del transporte
público con una campaña publicitaria en
la década de 1980 la autoridad de
tránsito introdujo boletos de colores
[Música]
pero la llegada de la tarjeta
electrónica navego en el año 2000 marcó
un nuevo capítulo ahora la próxima
revolución está en marcha pues los
usuarios pueden comprar boletos
directamente en sus teléfonos móviles